One of my coworkers here at This American Life , Robyn, was visiting New Orleans two years ago on a family vacation. And they had never been to New Orleans before. And they took one of those bus tours of the city-- you know, where it would show you the sights and the French Quarter. And then there was some, you know, look at this telephone pole. You can see the mark for how high the water got during Hurricane Katrina.
我在《This American Life》的同事Robyn，两年前曾去新奥尔良家庭旅行。他们之前从没去过那里。他们参加了一个城市观光巴士之旅——你知道的，就是那种带你看名胜古迹和法国区的旅行。然后中间会有一些，你知道的，“看那根电线杆，你能看到卡特里娜飓风期间水位涨到多高留下的痕迹”。
The tour guide was an older black man, a local. She said he was really good. And there's this one moment during the tour that really stuck out. It was late in the tour. They're driving to the Lower Ninth Ward.
导游是一位上了年纪的黑人，当地人。她说他真的很棒。在旅途中有一个瞬间真的让我印象深刻。那是行程快结束的时候，他们正开车前往下九区。
And as we were coming toward it, our tour bus guide says, so look. We used to go down into this area,  the Lower Ninth Ward. It was really badly hit in the storm. You know that. But we stopped going down there because we learned that the people there just really-- they didn't like the tours.
当我们靠近那里时，我们的旅游巴士导游说，看，我们过去常去这个区域，下九区。它在飓风中受灾非常严重。你们知道的。但我们不再去那边了，因为我们了解到那里的人真的……他们不喜欢这些旅游团。
They don't like the tours. They don't want people to come in and look at them and stare at them and look at how bad it is. And so we're not going to go in there.
他们不喜欢旅游团。他们不想让人进来盯着他们看，观察他们，看这里有多惨。所以我们不打算进去了。
And it stuck with me. I just believed that he was saying something that meant something to him. It seemed like he was saying something sincere, like we don't do this, and we're not doing it for the right reason. And so I'll show you some other stuff. But this is off-limits.
这句话深深印在我的脑海里。我坚信他说的话对他而言有着某种意义。他看起来说得很诚恳，仿佛在说我们不该这么做，我们这样做的初衷是不对的。所以我带你们看点别的东西吧。但这里是禁区。
The tour guide may have been sincere. But in addition, it's illegal for tour buses to go into the Lower Ninth Ward. The city council made it illegal starting in 2006, because buses were in the way of cleanup crews. But the rule was widely ignored till 2012, when homeowners went to the city council to finally get it enforced.
导游可能确实是诚恳的。但此外，旅游巴士进入下九区其实是违法的。市议会从2006年起就将其定为非法，因为巴士阻碍了清理工作。但这条规定在2012年之前一直被广泛无视，直到房主们向市议会施压，才最终得到执行。
It really made me angry. I felt as if you're looking at me through an eye that says, oh, look, there's another little animal in the zoo.
这真的让我很生气。我感觉他就好像在用一种眼光看着我，仿佛在说，噢，看，动物园里又多了一只小动物。
Gwen Adams is one of the homeowners who went to the city council about the bus tours. Kim Ford's another homeowner.
Gwen Adams是向市议会反映巴士旅游问题的房主之一。Kim Ford是另一位房主。
I'm not saying that they will come in here to gawk at people, no. I don't think there's anything mean spirited about it at all. I think they have a genuine interest to want to know how are the people doing, what's going on with them. I get that. But guess what? That's not the way you do that.
我不是说他们进来就是为了盯着人看，不是的。我不认为这有什么恶意。我认为他们确实是真心想了解人们过得怎么样，发生了什么。我明白这一点。但你猜怎么着？那不是了解情况的方式。
It was just so impersonal, people say. That's part of what felt so weird.
人们说，这种方式太缺乏人性了。这也是让人感觉如此怪异的一部分原因。
Back when I was in school, like, every day I look outside, there's like a tour bus coming through. And there's like 50, 60 people on the bus-- the big, air-conditioned, super comfortable ones. You would never see who was on the buses, because they wouldn't get off. They just come through, and then leave.
还在上学的时候，我每天往外看，都有那种旅游巴士经过。车上有50、60个人——那种大型的、空调充足、超级舒适的巴士。你永远看不到车上的人，因为他们根本不下车。他们只是穿过，然后就离开了。
This is Jamal Preston. He's 18, just graduated high school. His family returned to the Lower Ninth two years after Katrina.
这是Jamal Preston。他18岁，刚从高中毕业。他的家人在卡特里娜飓风后两年回到了下九区。
Like they're coming through just for the sake of, like, oh, look at how terrible-- sympathy, aw. But your sympathy is because something bad happened to people. Your sympathy is not based on the people that you actually met in the neighborhood that had to deal with it. It's a whole different level.
他们过来就像只是为了，噢，看看这里多惨——那种同情，哎呀。但你的同情是因为人们遭遇了不幸。你的同情并非基于你在社区里真正遇到过的、不得不面对这一切的人。那是完全不同的层面。
The 10th anniversary of Hurricane Katrina is this month. You probably heard that. There's been a ton of coverage-- remembering what happened, and stories about the rebuilding. But the Lower Ninth, this place that the bus tour will not take you into, is a special case, because this is the part of the city that was not supposed to come back.
本月是卡特里娜飓风10周年。你可能听说了。媒体对此进行了大量报道——纪念发生的一切，讲述重建的故事。但下九区，这个旅游巴士不会带你进入的地方，是一个特殊案例，因为这是城市中原本被认为无法恢复的部分。
You remember this, right after the storm? City officials said, forget it. Don't get anybody back there. The mayor's planning commission wanted to turn it to green space, basically a public park.
记得吗，飓风刚过后？市政官员说，算了吧。别让人回去了。市长的规划委员会想把它变成绿地，基本上就是一个公共公园。
And when they decided to not make it a green space?
当他们决定不把它变成绿地时？
I guess, well, then-- excuse my French-- but enough hell was raised, they figured they better do something different.
我想，好吧，那——请原谅我的粗鲁——但闹得够凶了，他们觉得还是做点别的比较好。
This is Henry Irvin, one of the hell raisers, 79-year-old who's been called the mayor of the Lower Ninth by New Orleans' actual mayor.
这是Henry Irvin，抗议者之一，79岁，被新奥尔良现任市长称为下九区的“市长”。
And then a lot of people started coming back. And then the city put in a lot of stumbling blocks too, see.
然后很多人开始回来。但城市也设下了很多绊脚石，你看。
Investigative reporter Gary Rivlin did a nice summary of those stumbling blocks recently. The Lower Ninth was the last neighborhood in the city to get electricity and drinking water. Residents were allowed back months after they were allowed into other neighborhoods. FEMA trailers were slower to arrive here. Only one school was reopened, and that only happened after teachers and parents cut the padlock on the building and marched on the superintendent's office.
调查记者Gary Rivlin最近对这些绊脚石做了一个很好的总结。下九区是全市最后一个通电和通自来水的社区。居民比其他社区的居民晚了数月才获准回来。联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的拖车在这里出现得更晚。只有一所学校重新开放，那还是在老师和家长剪断建筑挂锁并游行前往督学办公室之后才发生的。
Meanwhile, money allocated for homeowners to rebuild their houses-- $10 billion of assistance for Katrina victims throughout Louisiana was distributed by the state in a way that discriminated against black homeowners. That's what a federal judge ruled in 2010. And it's black homeowners who are in the Lower Ninth. Because of all this, most people did not come back.
与此同时，分配给房主重建房屋的资金——路易斯安那州全州100亿美元的卡特里娜飓风受害者援助金，其分配方式歧视黑人房主。这是联邦法官在2010年的裁定。而下九区的房主都是黑人。正因如此，大多数人没能回来。
The population of the ward is a little less than half of what it was before the storm. So half the homes are back. And they're bunched up at the bottom end of the ward, the high ground near the Mississippi, with bit patches of nothing in the top half, where Mr. Irvin lives.
该区的人口不到飓风前的一半。所以只有一半的房子回来了。它们聚集在该区的最底端，密西西比河附近的高地，而在Irvin先生居住的北半部，则是一片片荒地。
They started working on that house. This house has been totally repaired. This house, they haven't done anything on it.
他们开始修理那栋房子。这栋房子已经完全修好了。这栋房子，他们什么都没做。
And are they going to tear that down? They're going to be able to [INAUDIBLE].
他们要把那栋拆了吗？他们能……
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）
I'd seen pictures of the Lower Ninth Ward-- probably you have, too. But they didn't prepare me for what it's like to drive around the north half of the ward, the part above North Claiborne Street. It's like wilderness. But it's a very orderly wilderness-- a grid of streets laid out like a town waiting for developers who never showed up-- which, you know, it is-- tall grass filling the space between lots.
我见过下九区的照片——可能你也见过。但这些照片没法让我准备好去面对驾车穿过该区北半部、即北克莱伯恩街以上部分时的感受。那就像是一片荒野。但这是一片非常有秩序的荒野——街道呈网格状布局，就像一个在等待开发商却始终没等到的小镇——你知道，事实确实如此——高高的杂草填满了地块之间的空隙。
So there was a grocery store here on this corner one time.
那个路口曾经有一家杂货店。
Now it's just a foundation there.
现在那里只剩下一个地基。
It's just a foundation, that's all. This used to be [INAUDIBLE] school right here. It's just an empty piece of land.
只是个地基，仅此而已。这里曾经是（听不清）学校。现在只是一块空地。
Outside the Lower Ninth, in the rest of the city, the population is 90% back to what it was before the storm. Who you meet when you travel around the Lower Ninth are just some very willful people who've dealt with some of the worst destruction in the city and who are dealing with a lot of ghosts. It's still not clear exactly how many people in New Orleans died in Katrina. The official count is about 1,000, a third of those by drowning. More of those were in the Lower Ninth than any other neighborhood.
在下九区之外的城市其他地方，人口已经恢复到飓风前水平的90%。在下九区旅行时你会遇到一些非常坚韧的人，他们经历过市内最严重的破坏，并且一直在与许多幽灵打交道。目前还不清楚新奥尔良在卡特里娜飓风中究竟有多少人死亡。官方统计约为1000人，其中三分之一死于溺水。下九区的遇难者比其他任何社区都多。
Today on our program, we're going to take you on a walking tour of the Lower Ninth. We're going to make six stops. And at each stop, we're going to do what the bus tour cannot do. We're going to meet some people.
今天在节目中，我们将带你进行一次下九区的步行游览。我们将安排六站。在每一站，我们都会做巴士旅游无法做到的事。我们将去见见当地的人们。
And think about this for a second. This is the neighborhood that the city did not want to exist. This is the neighborhood that has come back the least from Katrina. So of all the extreme situations you could get into after the storm, these people have been in the most extreme. So what's that been like? Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We find out. Stay with us.
试想一下。这是城市原本不想让它存在的社区。这是从卡特里娜飓风中恢复最慢的社区。所以，在飓风后所有你能遇到的极端境遇中，这些人经历的是最极端的。那是什么样的体验？来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。让我们一探究竟。请继续收听。
OK, so like I said, this is going to be a walking tour. And our first stop is going to be the northeast corner of St. Claude Avenue and Gordon Street. So face the street. Just to orient you real fast, the Lower Ninth is basically a rectangle with water on three sides of the rectangle. So as you stand here facing the street, the Mississippi is a few blocks in front of you. The bayou is a little ways behind you. And the Industrial Canal's to your right a bunch of blocks.
好吧，就像我说的，这是一次步行游览。第一站是圣克劳德大道和戈登街的东北角。面向街道站好。为了让你快速辨别方向，下九区基本是一个三面环水的矩形。当你站在这里面向街道时，密西西比河就在你前方几个街区处。河口在你身后不远。工业运河在你右侧几个街区外。
It's all pretty close. The Lower Ninth is just 20 blocks wide-- just a little over a mile. And if you turn around now and you face this building on the corner, what you see is a two-story building. And the first story is faded brick. And those bricks were damaged during Katrina by rescue boats that knocked into it. A Wildlife and Fisheries guy told the current owner of this building 50 people were rescued from the balcony on the second floor.
离得都很近。下九区只有20个街区宽——仅一英里多一点。如果你现在转身面对拐角的这栋建筑，你会看到一栋两层楼高的建筑。一楼是褪色的砖墙。那些砖块在卡特里娜飓风期间被撞击它的救援船损坏了。一位野生动物和渔业局的人告诉这栋建筑的现任房主，有50人从二楼的阳台上被救出。
So back in the day, locals will tell you that this was a medical clinic. These days, it's a cafe-- well, more than a cafe. You see the hand lettered sign out front that lists red bean and rice special, ribs, computer service, VA benefits, seafood. And the guy that we're here to talk to is one of those people who has thrown his whole life now into trying to push the Lower Ninth into the future, Kirk Washington. Everybody just calls him Washington. Robyn spent a bunch of time with him.
回到过去，当地人会告诉你这曾是一家医疗诊所。如今，它是一家咖啡馆——好吧，不仅仅是咖啡馆。你看到门前那块手写的牌子了吗，上面列着红豆饭特餐、排骨、电脑维修、退伍军人福利、海鲜。我们要拜访的人是那些现在全身心投入到推动下九区走向未来的人之一，Kirk Washington。每个人都叫他Washington。Robyn和他相处了很长时间。
Washington is the least retired retired person I've ever met, thanks to Katrina. He opened this cafe.
多亏了卡特里娜飓风，Washington是我见过最不像退休人士的退休人员。他开了这家咖啡馆。
Ah, it's [INAUDIBLE] in the cafe, baby.
啊，在咖啡馆里（听不清），宝贝。
Every day but Sunday, when the cafe's closed, he's here. Washington's a retired postal worker. He didn't know anything about running a cafe. After Katrina, he just saw that there was no place to send a fax or photocopy anything or look stuff up online, which you need to do with construction permits and home inspectors and FEMA and the city. So he thought, I'll build that.
除了周日闭店外，他每天都在这儿。Washington是一位退休的邮政工人。他一点也不懂经营咖啡馆。飓风过后，他只是发现没地方可以发传真、复印东西或上网查询信息，而处理建筑许可、房屋检查、联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）和市政事务时都需要用到这些。所以他想，我自己建一个。
Then he kept going with other things they needed-- food, a game room with pool tables, a small clothing store, a recording studio. One day, I watched him help a resident apply for a home loan, rack a pool table for some kids, cook burgers and sandwiches for six people, and fax someone's proof of employment, all in under an hour. He also rents rooms to people for cheap-- he owns two houses-- so folks can afford to get back on their feet. He does all this for one reason.
后来他又继续增加了其他大家需要的东西——食物、带台球桌的游戏室、一家小型服装店、一家录音棚。有一天，我看着他帮一位居民申请住房贷款，给孩子们的台球桌摆好球，为六个人做汉堡和三明治，还帮某人传真了工作证明，所有这一切都在一小时内完成。他还以低价将房屋出租给人们——他拥有两栋房子——这样大家就能负担得起重新站起来。他做这一切只有一个理由。
To benefit the neighborhood, to bring the neighborhood back, you know.
为了造福社区，让社区恢复原貌，你知道的。
Washington's lived in the Lower Ninth Ward since the late '70s. He bought his house in the '80s, bought the property next door to it too, fixed them both up. He stayed during Katrina because he's one of those people who always stays during a hurricane. An estimated 2,000 people in the Lower Ninth Ward decided to stay. 10 years later he thinks all the time about that decision to stay.
Washington自70年代末就住在下九区。他在80年代买了房子，又买下了隔壁的房产，把它们都修缮好了。卡特里娜飓风期间他留了下来，因为他是那种在飓风期间总是不走的人。据估计，下九区有2000人决定留下。10年后，他时常想起那个留下的决定。
I've been all over the world. I've been all through Vietnam, everywhere. When that hurricane hit, I had never been that scared before in my whole life-- my whole life. I've been through a whole lot of things, scary, scary things, but that was as scared as I've ever been in my whole life.
我走遍了全世界。我去过越南，去过各地。飓风来袭时，我这辈子从未像那时那样害怕过——我的一生。我经历过很多事情，可怕的、非常可怕的事情，但那是我这辈子最害怕的时刻。
Here's how Washington survived the storm. Sunday the 28th, the mayor orders the mandatory evacuation. That night, Washington is at home with three of his neighbors-- the Taylors from next door and Isaac from across the street. They plan on riding out the storm together.
以下是Washington在飓风中幸存的经过。28日周日，市长下达了强制疏散令。那天晚上，Washington和三位邻居在一起——隔壁的Taylor夫妇和街对面的Isaac。他们计划一起挺过飓风。
Early morning on the 29th the hurricane hits, winds over a hundred miles per hour. Washington calls the flying debris shrapnel, because it would kill you. At his house, the group isn't sure what to do.
29日凌晨飓风来袭，风速超过每小时100英里。Washington把飞来的残骸称为弹片，因为它们足以致命。在他的房子里，大家不确定该怎么办。
I said, this is going to be dangerous, man. I said, y'all could stay if y'all want. But if y'all want to go, I think y'all should go and buckle down.
我说，这会很危险，伙计。我说，你们如果想留就留吧。但如果你们想走，我觉得你们应该走，赶快躲好。
Everyone goes home. The levees fail. The entire Lower Ninth Ward floods.
大家都回了家。大堤决堤了。整个下九区被淹没。
All I could hear was this, when that water came. I could hear little babies howling and screaming. I could hear ladies hollering and screaming. I heard my neighbor hollering and screaming. The air was full of noise, people that was in dire need for someone to help them. I mean, people was really drowning. They were drowning.
当水涌过来时，我只能听到这些声音。我能听到婴儿的啼哭和尖叫声。我能听到女士们的呼喊和尖叫。我听到邻居在呼喊和尖叫。空气中充满了声音，人们迫切需要有人救他们。我是说，人们真的在溺水。他们在溺水。
And, you know, there was nothing you could do. That was the hardest part about things. What can you do? I mean, you can't go out there, the wind is still-- you still have shrapnel flying all through the air. The water's rising so fast that, hey, you know, how are you going to negotiate the water?
而且，你知道，你什么也做不了。那是事情最艰难的部分。你能做什么？我的意思是，你不能出去，风还在吹——到处仍有弹片在飞舞。水涨得太快了，嘿，你知道，你怎么能在水中行动？
Yeah, I could swim. But guess what? I don't want to take no chances getting into the water. It was one thing that nobody should want to experience in their whole life.
是的，我会游泳。但你猜怎么着？我不想冒险下水。那是任何人一生都不该经历的事情。
It got to the point that our neighbors, we started coming out to survey what was going on. Well, one of my neighbors drowned.
到了最后，我们的邻居，我们开始出来察看发生了什么。嗯，我的一位邻居溺水了。
One of your friends who was in your house earlier that night?
那天晚上早些时候在你家里的一位朋友？
Yes.
是的。
That was Isaac. His full name was Isaac Castle. He was 58.
那是Isaac。他的全名是Isaac Castle。他58岁。
You feel you was a failure, you know what I'm saying? Because you could help, but you didn't. But it's the thing inside you that says, well, man, I could've did more than what I did. And it just kind of gets to you a little bit, because this person is gone, you know. And I didn't do anything about it. But I thought he was going to be safe. He couldn't swim. He couldn't swim.
你会觉得你是个失败者，你知道我在说什么吗？因为你可以帮忙，但你没有。但这是一种内心深处的感觉，它说，伙计，我本可以做得更多。这确实有点折磨人，因为这个人已经走了，你知道的。而我什么也没做。但我以为他是安全的。他不会游泳。他不会游泳。
Washington got picked up by a Wildlife and Fisheries boat and made his way to Baton Rouge. Two days after Katrina, he got himself to a Dodge dealership, figuring no matter what, he's going to need a car. And that's where, standing alone in a used car lot, exhausted, he started to feel something for the first time in days.
Washington被一艘野生动物和渔业局的船接走，辗转到了巴吞鲁日。卡特里娜飓风两天后，他去了道奇车行，心想无论如何，他都需要一辆车。就在那里，独自一人站在二手车行里，疲惫不堪，他第一次在几天内感受到了什么。
Of all the destruction and all the death and all the hollering and screaming, is just hit me. I mean, it was just like a whole three-story building just crushing me, like a tornado going around in my head. It was just like, wow, all these things have happened, and I'm just blinking my eyes and just seeing all of them at one time. It was just like a nightmare.
在所有的破坏、死亡、呼喊和尖叫之后，它只是击中了我。我的意思是，感觉就像整栋三层楼压在我身上，像头脑中旋转的龙卷风。感觉就像是，哇，所有这些事情都发生了，我只是眨了眨眼，就同时看到了这一切。这简直就是一场噩梦。
I came to reality like, man, man, look. Did I go through all this? I'm really alive and this really did happen. You know what I'm saying? Everything that happened, everything that happened, this is real. This is real. It just hit me. It just hit me.
我回归了现实，心想，伙计，看看。我经历了这一切吗？我真的还活着，这真的发生了。你知道我在说什么吗？发生的一切，发生的一切，这是真的。这是真的。它击中了我。它击中了我。
What happened? You started crying?
发生了什么？你开始哭了吗？
Yeah. That was it. People, they was standing, watching. And they couldn't deal with it, so they went in the room. And they talk and talk and talk. And one of the guys came, after he saw me. I quieted down some.
是的。就是那样。人们，他们站在那儿，看着。他们无法面对，所以他们回到了房间。他们谈论、谈论、谈论。看到我这样，其中一个人走过来。我平静了一些。
The salesman?
那个销售员吗？
Yeah. He said, man, I have a car for you. He said, you could get it right now. We're not going to charge you too much. So I pay in cash for the car. And I got  on the highway. It was just one thing after another.
是的。他说，伙计，我有一辆车给你。他说，你现在就可以拿走。我们不会收你太多钱。所以我付现金买下了车。我就上了高速公路。事情一件接一件。
He bought a white truck, drove it to Corpus Christi, Texas, and back home three weeks after the storm, during a time when most people weren't allowed back into the Lower Ninth Ward. Washington says his veterans ID card worked as a pass. And he rebuilt both his houses, one piece of sheet rock and one birchwood panel at a time.
他买了一辆白色皮卡，开了它到德克萨斯州的科珀斯克里斯蒂，然后在飓风后三周回到家，当时大多数人还不被允许进入下九区。Washington说他的退伍军人证就像通行证一样好用。他修好了两栋房子，一块石膏板、一块桦木板地修起来。
I spent a lot of time talking with Washington on three different days. And he never bragged or complained about anything. But I wanted to know what he lost in the storm, which is how I learned about the cars.
我花了很多时间在三天里和Washington交谈。他从不吹嘘或抱怨任何事。但我很想知道他在飓风中失去了什么，这就是我了解那些车的原因。
I lost a Mercedes Benz. I lost a Jaguar. I lost a BMW. I lost a Ford F-150.
我失去了一辆奔驰。我失去了一辆捷豹。我失去了一辆宝马。我失去了一辆福特F-150。
He told me he got them right after he retired. He took his savings and bought them at auction, a car a year for four years. He got the last one just a year before the storm. He loved driving around in those cars. It was indulgent, after a life of saving money and working at the post office.
他告诉我他在退休后立刻买了这些车。他拿出积蓄在拍卖会上买下它们，四年里每年买一辆车。他在飓风前一年买的最后一辆。他喜欢开着这些车到处转。这是一种放纵，在他一生省吃俭用并在邮局工作之后。
I don't talk about it that much. But when I get in my car, I'm sick as a dog, because I don't have these cars. I really don't want another one of those cars, because it's going to remind me, and I feel that I'm going to be more sicker than what I am.
我不怎么谈论这个。但当我走进车里时，我难受得要命，因为我没有这些车了。我真的不想再买那一类的车，因为它会提醒我，我觉得我会比现在更难受。
You'll be more upset?
你会更沮丧？
Yeah. Sick, sick to my stomach, like this thing in your stomach-- nerves, probably.
是的。难受，胃里难受，像胃里的东西——可能是神经吧。
Your stomach hurts a lot?
你的胃经常痛吗？
It just has that little funny feeling. And when I get that funny feeling, I know it's something that's triggering it, and it's coming from my mind. It's coming from my head.
它只是有一种那种奇怪的感觉。当我产生那种奇怪的感觉时，我知道有什么东西在触发它，它来自我的思维。它来自我的脑袋。
Here's the tangle for Washington. He's throwing all this energy into rebuilding and making everything new again. But all the new stuff that he has now, like his new bathroom and his new house, his new business, everything new reminds him of what was old, daily.
这就是Washington的困境。他投入所有精力去重建，让一切焕然一新。但他现在拥有的所有新东西，比如他的新浴室、新房子、新生意，所有新的东西每天都在提醒他旧的事物。
Brushing his teeth with running water reminds him of when, after the storm, he couldn't do that. Turning on a light reminds him how for a while after the storm, he didn't have electricity. It doesn't stop, no matter how he tries to keep busy.
用自来水刷牙提醒他飓风后有一段时间他做不到。开灯提醒他飓风后有一段时间他没有电。无论他怎么努力让自己忙碌，这都停不下来。
I need things to do so that I won't get caught up in this mind thing, you know what I'm saying. So in order for me not to, I have to occupy my mind with something. I have to, because if I don't, my mind is going to play tricks on me. Do you daydream?
我需要事情做，这样我就不会陷入这种思维陷阱里，你知道我在说什么吗？所以为了不这样，我必须用别的东西填满我的大脑。我必须这样做，因为如果我不做，我的头脑就会跟我玩花招。你做白日梦吗？
Sometimes.
有时。
OK. I hate daydreaming. Do you have nightmares?
好吧。我讨厌做白日梦。你有噩梦吗？
Sometimes.
有时。
You see that? "Sometimes." It's constant. Do you have illusions of things while you're driving? Like you're driving your car, and you think that you driving this Mercedes Benz or this Jaguar? You see what I'm saying? I mean, I can't hide from it. It's real.
你看到了吗？“有时”。这是持续不断的。你在开车时有幻觉吗？比如你在开车，你以为你开的是这辆奔驰或捷豹？你明白我的意思吗？我的意思是，我躲不开它。这是真的。
I know it's there. I know what the symptoms are. I know it's impossible for me to treat it. It's impossible, because daily things are going to bring me to it. Talking to you right now is bringing me to it.
我知道它在那里。我知道症状是什么。我知道治愈它对我来说是不可能的。这是不可能的，因为日常的事物总会把我带回那里。现在和你谈话就在把我带回那里。
I walk out the front of my house, and I look over at that door, I see my friend. I see Isaac. Then I have to let it go. Let it go. I come down this street. When I'm looking down from the bridge up there, I'm seeing nothing but the top of houses all water. And I'm riding down the same street.
我走到房子前，看向那扇门，我看到了我的朋友。我看到了Isaac。然后我必须放下它。放下它。我沿着这条街走。当我从上面的桥上往下看时，我看到的只有水淹过房顶。我沿着同一条街行驶。
I mean, what? It's constant. It's something that-- the hurricane was just five years ago.
我的意思是，什么？这是持续不断的。这是……飓风才过去五年。
10 years.
10年。
10 years ago. Look at that. It's there. It's still there. It's just there.
10年前。看看这个。它在那里。它依然在那里。它就在那里。
Washington points to people in his cafe. They're mostly storm survivors. He says, talk to them. They're suffering, too. He tells me about a customer, a woman who lost her home in the storm, has completely rebuilt it, but won't move back in. Washington doesn't think she ever will.
Washington指着咖啡馆里的人。他们大多是飓风幸存者。他说，去和他们谈谈。他们也正在受苦。他告诉我一个顾客，一个在飓风中失去房子、已经完全重建但拒绝搬回去的女人。Washington认为她永远不会搬回去。
She's afraid, he says. You can see it in her eyes when she talks about the house. I tell him I think I know what he means. I can see fear in his eyes, too. He laughs and says, no, you can't see it. You have to have gone through it to understand.
他说，她很害怕。当你谈论那房子时，你可以从她的眼中看出来。我告诉他我想我明白他的意思。我也能在他眼中看到恐惧。他笑了笑说，不，你看不出来。你必须亲身经历过才能理解。
Robyn Semien.
Robyn Semien报道。
We're on a walking tour of the Lower Ninth this hour. Kirk Washington's house is all the way on the bottom of the Lower Ninth, right near the Mississippi. That's higher ground. That's the part of the Lower Ninth that survived the most. Houses are jammed together here, and most of them are occupied.
本小时我们正在下九区进行步行游览。Kirk Washington的房子在下九区的最底端，靠近密西西比河。那是地势较高的地方。那是下九区受损程度最低的部分。房子在这里挤在一起，大多数都有人居住。
And just a two-minute walk from Washington's house, five blocks away, there's a bar that Kim Ford, who you heard at the top of the show, brought one of our producers, Zoe Chace to. She was like, go to this bar. It's the best.
从Washington家步行仅需两分钟，五个街区外，有一家酒吧，就是节目开头提到的Kim Ford带我们的一位制作人Zoe Chace去的那家。她说，去这家酒吧。这是最好的。
Call out the street name. Tell America.
叫出街道名。告诉美国。
America, this is Lizardi and Burgundy. And this place is a staple in the Lower Ninth Ward, Mercedes Bar. Everybody in the Lower Ninth Ward knows this place.
美国，这是Lizardi街和Burgundy街路口。这个地方是下九区的支柱，梅赛德斯酒吧。下九区的所有人都知道这个地方。
Mercedes Bar is one of the few bars they have here now. One local told us it was nine bars before Katrina. It's just two now. This is the second stop on our tour.
梅赛德斯酒吧是他们现在这里仅有的几家酒吧之一。一位当地人告诉我们卡特里娜飓风前有九家。现在只有两家了。这是我们行程的第二站。
As you face the building, you can see that it is neatly painted white with green trim around the windows, little New Orleans fleur-de-lis in gold and black. It looks well taken care of, which is not true of the street in front of it, you will notice if you turn that way. So many streets in the Lower Ninth are just awful, and this is one of them. Lots of potholes, and they're big potholes.
面对建筑，你可以看到它漆得整整齐齐，白色墙身配着绿色窗框，小小的金黑色新奥尔良鸢尾花装饰。它看起来保养得很好，但如果你转过身看前面的街道，你会发现街道状况可就不一样了。下九区的许多街道都太糟糕了，这就是其中之一。到处都是坑洼，而且是很大的坑洼。
And if you pull in there, you're going down in a hole. The streets are horrible. A little bit of rain, and it's water everywhere. You can't even park here.
如果你把车开进去，你就会掉进洞里。街道太可怕了。稍微下点雨，到处都是水。你甚至没法停车。
The owner of the bar, Mercedes Gibson, says that the holes in the street are costing her customers and they're costing her money. And it's hard to pay the light bill at this point. Zoe spent some time with her and her customers.
酒吧老板Mercedes Gibson说，街上的洞让她流失了客源，也让她损失了金钱。现在连电费都很难付。Zoe和她以及她的客人们在一起呆了一段时间。
The holes in the streets are a real problem for Mercedes, because neither she nor her customers are young.
街上的洞对Mercedes来说是个真正的问题，因为她和她的客人都不是年轻人。
Well, I describe it as a friendly bar and settle-aged people. I don't fool with youngsters.
嗯，我形容它是一家友好的酒吧，住着一些定居下来的中年人。我不跟小年轻混。
"Settle-aged people," like the bartender, Mercedes' daughter, Sharon. She polls the bar for me real quick to prove how dire the Lizardi Street parking situation really is.
“定居下来的中年人”，比如酒保，Mercedes的女儿Sharon。为了证明Lizardi街的停车位情况有多严峻，我快速调查了酒吧里的情况。
How far did you all have to park to get here?
你们大家为了到这里得停多远？
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
Block away.
一个街区远。
A block and a half.
一个半街区。
Two. I parked two blocks away.
两个。我停在两个街区外。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
Are y'all young people, or senior citizens?
你们是年轻人，还是老年人？
I'm a senior citizen.
我是老年人。
I don't know about the rest of them, but I'm young.
我不清楚其他人，但我还年轻。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I'm almost 70 years old.
我快70岁了。
And I'm 71 young.
我才71岁，还年轻着呢。
Are y'all happy about walking a block and a half to get here?
你们对为了到这儿来得走一个半街区感到高兴吗？
No!
不！
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交叉的人声）
So I sit with the settle-aged at a long table in the middle of the bar.
所以我坐在酒吧中间的长桌旁，和这些定居者坐在一起。
Are you running away?
你要逃跑吗？
Uh-uh. No, I'm [INAUDIBLE]. Have a seat.
嗯-嗯。不，我（听不清）。请坐。
OK.
好的。
I ask about the storm, and it's like it just happened. The switch clicks right off the potholes and onto scenes from 10 years ago. Jean Gibson is nursing Crown Royal and water. She's a young-looking 60-year-old. During the storm, she was with her first husband and two grandkids. They evacuated to Houston first and stayed in a hotel for a while.
我问起飓风的事，就像它刚发生一样。对话立刻从坑洼转到了10年前的场景。Jean Gibson正在喝皇冠威士忌加水。她是一个看起来只有60岁的年轻女人。飓风期间，她和第一任丈夫以及两个孙辈在一起。他们先疏散到了休斯顿，在酒店里住了一段时间。
I was in one, but they put me out.
我住过一家，但他们把我赶了出来。
Why?
为什么？
Because our money ran out. [LAUGHS]
因为我们的钱花光了。（笑）
Their credit card hit the limit. When she went to the ATM, she found out that her bank back in New Orleans was out. The ATMs couldn't connect. She was stuck in Texas with no money. So she did something she never thought she'd have to do.
他们的信用卡刷爆了。当她去自动取款机时，发现新奥尔良的银行没钱了。取款机无法连接。她被困在德克萨斯州，身无分文。所以她做了一件她从未想过自己会做的事。
And that was to beg, to sit on a curb with a one- and a two-year-old in Dallas with nowhere to go. And I sat on the curb, because they needed Pampers, they needed food. And I sit at that Kmart parking lot. And I sat on that curb, and I begged every car that came out that parking lot.
那就是乞讨，在达拉斯坐在路边，身边带着一两岁的孩子，无处可去。我坐在马路牙子上，因为他们需要尿布，他们需要食物。我坐在那个凯马特停车场的马路牙子上。我拦住每一辆离开停车场的车乞讨。
Keep this in mind. Jean was a middle class lady, a homeowner living comfortably. Before Katrina, she says, one paycheck paid all her bills for the month. She worked for the city. She ran the benefits department for all the city workers.
记住这一点。Jean曾经是一位中产阶级女士，生活舒适的房主。卡特里娜飓风前，她说，一份工资就足以支付她一个月的账单。她在市政府工作。她负责全市所有市政工作人员的福利部门。
I mean I wore $95 blouses to work. I had Coach pocketbooks. And my husband was an extremely sharp dresser. Oh, he was a sharp dresser-- good-looking, sharp-dressing man. He wore $75 belts. That was nothing for us.
我的意思是，我穿95美元一件的衬衫上班。我有Coach钱包。我丈夫穿着极其讲究。噢，他是个穿着讲究的人——长得帅、穿着讲究的男人。他戴75美元的腰带。这对我们来说不算什么。
This is the person who found herself begging for help in a parking lot, saying things like--
这就是那个发现自己在一个停车场乞求帮助的人，说着这样的话——
If you could just give me some Pampers. Just some pampers, and food for the children. You don't have to give me nothing, just some food for the children.
如果你能给我一些尿布就好了。只要一些尿布，还有给孩子们的食物。你什么都不用给，只要给孩子们一些食物就行。
And a white guy in a black pickup truck, he said, miss, you from New Orleans? And I said, yes sir. I said, my children are hungry. And they're still in the same diapers for three days. I would take the diaper and scrape the diaper and put it back on them, because I had no choice.
一个开着黑色皮卡的白人男士说，女士，你是从新奥尔良来的吗？我说，是的，先生。我说，我的孩子们饿坏了。他们已经三天穿着同一条尿布了。我只好把尿布刮干净再给他们穿上，因为我没别的办法。
And the man, he took me in Kmart and bought me a box of Pampers and some of them macaronis. But I had nowhere to--
那个男人，他带我进了凯马特，给我买了一箱尿布和一些通心粉。但我没地方……
The noodles?
面条吗？
The noodles. But I didn't nowhere to cook it. So I took them, I opened them, and I put that little sauce in them, and they ate dried noodles. And they were kids. That's a treat for them.
面条。但我没地方煮。所以我拿了它们，打开包装，放了点调味汁，他们吃了干面条。他们还是孩子。那是他们的款待。
[INAUDIBLE]. I don't know about nobody else, but I tried it. It taste good. [LAUGHS]
（听不清）。我不知道别人怎么样，但我试过。味道不错。（笑）
Then we stayed there overnight in the car, kids hollering. They're hungry. I just kept washing my underwear in the gas station bathroom and putting them back on wet.
然后我们就在车里过了一夜，孩子们在尖叫。他们饿了。我只是不停地在加油站的洗手间里洗我的内衣，然后湿着穿上。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
The man at the Exxon Station told me, miss, because you're from New Orleans, I'm going to let you keep coming in here everyday and wash your underwear.
埃克森加油站的那个人告诉我，女士，因为你是新奥尔良来的，我让你每天都能进来洗内衣。
That's the least you could do, you know?
那是他能做的最起码的事情，你知道吗？
I was trying to sneak in there, because I didn't want the people to know I'm going to wash my drawers.
我当时试图悄悄溜进去，因为我不想让别人知道我要去洗内裤。
Think about what that must be like, to have your life change so abruptly, no transition. And I wanted to know, did she feel like she was suddenly a different person? No, she says. That's not what happens. She says you get very practical. It's just how do you solve the next problem?
想一想那会是什么感觉，你的生活如此突然地改变，没有任何过渡。我想知道，她是否觉得她突然变成了另一个人？不，她说。事情不是那样的。她说你会变得非常务实。只是怎么解决下一个问题？
All you think about is, what am I going to do? Well, I'm just going to beg.
你所想的全部就是，我该怎么办？好吧，我只能乞讨。
Had you ever begged before?
你之前乞讨过吗？
Oh, god, no.
噢，天哪，没有。
Did you go up to people's cars?
你走到人们的车前了吗？
Yes. Yes. I had the one-year-old in my arm, and the other one, I was holding his hand. And as people passed, I would even bang on their window.
是的。是的。我怀里抱着一岁的孩子，手里牵着另一个。当人们经过时，我甚至会敲他们的车窗。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. And ask them, can you please help me? Please help me and my babies. Because of the way I looked, they must have thought I was a crackhead or something, you know, using the babies. And let me tell you, the reason I thought that was because I used to think that.
是的。请求他们，能请帮帮我吗？请帮帮我和我的孩子。因为我看起来的样子，他们一定以为我是个瘾君子什么的，在利用孩子。让我告诉你，我之所以这样想，是因为我曾经也是那样看别人的。
Jean moved around Texas for a month. Then she got a call, five weeks after she left. Come back to your job in the city of New Orleans. And she thought, maybe things are finally going to be OK.
Jean在德克萨斯州辗转了一个月。然后她接到了一个电话，离开五周后。回新奥尔良市上班。她想，也许情况终于会好转了。
I never really thought I lost my life. That sounds crazy. I mean, I thought I was going to come sweep my house out.
我从未真正想过我失去了生活。这听起来很疯狂。我的意思是，我以为我会回来把我的房子扫干净。
With a broom.
用扫帚。
With a broom. You know, I knew the streets would probably have some dirt in it.
用扫帚。你知道，我知道街道上可能会有一些泥土。
Driving into New Orleans, early October. It was pitch black, no lights, just a few big military spotlights like a movie set, a movie set of a war zone-- soldiers everywhere, the hotels with the windows blown out, the streets coated in mud and white dirt, and so empty.
开车进入新奥尔良，十月初。漆黑一片，没有灯光，只有几盏军事探照灯像电影场景一样，一个战区的电影场景——到处都是士兵，酒店窗户破损，街道上覆盖着泥浆和白土，如此空旷。
And I said, Lord, have mercy, look at my city. And it hit me, yeah. It did hit me. But when I came across this canal, I knew there was no humanly way possible that this Ninth Ward could ever come back.
我说，主啊，发发慈悲，看看我的城市。它击中了我，是的。确实击中了我。但当我穿过这条运河时，我知道九区再也不可能恢复了。
The people that you knew, I don't see nobody that I know. People who know you, you know them, know your mama, know your daddy, know your brothers, know where you live, know y'all had a black dog one time-- I'm talking about those people. I'm talking about people you did your first communion with, and the people that would tell your mama you did something wrong.
我认识的人，我谁也没见到。认识你的人，你知道他们，知道你妈妈，知道你爸爸，知道你兄弟，知道你住哪儿，知道你们曾经有一只黑狗——我指的是那些人。我指的是那些和你一起做第一次圣餐的人，那些会告诉如果你做了错事就告诉妈妈的人。
You will never see them again. So who am I? I don't know.
你再也见不到他们了。所以我又是谁？我不知道。
Here is the identity crisis, not in the parking lot, begging for food. She just didn't know until she got home to New Orleans that there is no chance of being who she was before.
这就是身份危机，不是在停车场乞求食物的时候。直到她回到新奥尔良，她才知道再也没有机会成为过去的自己了。
Jean's house is completely rebuilt. Like other houses here I've seen, it kind of looks like a Pottery Barn showroom-- not lived in for very long; new matching furniture; nice, though, spacious. She's still working for the city. She has a new husband now. The husband she made it through the storm with, he died in 2007. Now she's married to the son of Mercy D., Mercedes, the bar owner. And she has this new big, big family to go with him. They gather at Mercedes Bar almost every day.
Jean的房子已经完全重建。像我在这里见过的其他房子一样，它看起来像一个Pottery Barn的展示间——没住多久；配了新的配套家具；不过，宽敞且美观。她依然在为市政府工作。她现在有了新的丈夫。和她一起挺过飓风的那位丈夫在2007年去世了。现在她嫁给了梅赛德斯酒吧老板Mercy D.的儿子。她有了一个巨大的新家庭。他们几乎每天都在梅赛德斯酒吧聚会。
And so it's like, yeah, you have a new life. But it looks like a good life. Is it a good life?
所以这就像是，是的，你有了一种新生活。但这看起来是个好生活。这是好生活吗？
Looks are deceiving. You make do with what you have. And you try every day to get that other life back-- yes, every day. Every, every day. But it's not coming back. But that's OK. Tomorrow coming. I ought to be able to get some little piece of it. And there's tomorrow coming. It doesn't come back.
外表是具有欺骗性的。你只能利用现有的东西凑合。你每天都试图把那段旧生活找回来——是的，每一天。每一天，每一天。但它回不来了。不过那也没关系。明天会来。我应该能够找回一点点片段。明天会来。它回不来了。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, drive your Chevy to the levee to where the levee was not dry. That's in a minute, when our tour of the Lower Ninth continues, from WBEZ Chicago, when our program continues.
Zoe Chace是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，开车去大堤，去到大堤不再干燥的地方。那就在一分钟后，当我们下九区的行程继续时，来自WBEZ芝加哥，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we have a tour of the Lower Ninth Ward, the part of New Orleans that has come back the least since Hurricane Katrina hit 10 years ago this week.
这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天在节目中，我们游览了下九区，这是自本周10年前卡特里娜飓风袭来以来新奥尔良恢复最慢的部分。
We've arrived at the third stop at our tour, the corner of Jordan Avenue and North Prieur Street, right across from one of the levees that collapsed a decade ago. If you stand here facing south with the levee to your right-- well, first of all, this is the part of town where Brad Pitt bought a bunch of houses with the Make it Right Foundation after the storm. And you see some of those right in front of you. They're boxy and moderne. Lots of them have solar panels. There are also a couple of regular houses on the streets, some overgrown yards.
我们到达了行程的第三站，乔丹大道和北普里厄街的拐角处，正对着十年前坍塌的一座大堤。如果你站在这里向南看，大堤在你的右侧——好吧，首先，这是布拉德·皮特在飓风后通过“Make it Right”基金会购买了一堆房子的地方。你可以在你面前看到一些。它们是方方正正、现代风格的。很多都有太阳能电池板。街上也有几栋普通房屋，还有一些杂草丛生。
The levee itself across those houses has a grassy embankment with a 14-foot concrete wall at the top. And most people you talk to down here will tell you the same thing about what happened right here at this spot on the levee on August 29, 2005.
横跨那些房屋的大堤本身有一条草堤，顶部有一道14英尺高的混凝土墙。大多数你在这里谈论的人都会告诉你关于2005年8月29日发生在大堤上的同一件事。
It was dynamited in six places on the Industrial Canal. They got people that live on this street who will go to their grave and tell you that they heard the dynamite.
它在工业运河的六个地方被炸毁了。住在这条街上的人会至死都告诉你，他们听到了炸药声。
And they heard an explosion, and then the water start coming up the streets. That's just to keep the water from going downtown, Bourbon Street. Because they didn't get no water. They just blew the damn thing and send it this way.
他们听到了爆炸声，然后水开始漫过街道。那只是为了防止水流向市中心，波旁街。因为他们没被淹。他们只是炸了那个该死的东西，把它引向这边。
Lots of people heard an explosion. And lots of people say it was the government. The government blew up the levees to get black people out of the Lower Ninth. Lucrece Phillips lived on the other side of the canal. And she said flooding had started that morning, but it wasn't much-- like as high as your car tires.
很多人都听到了爆炸声。很多人说那是政府干的。政府炸毁了大堤，是为了把黑人赶出下九区。Lucrece Phillips曾住在运河的另一边。她说当天早上水开始上涨，但不多——就像车轮那么高。
Then all of a sudden we hear a boom, like the windows were sucked out. Now, we have them taped and all, so they just wanted to blast, but they couldn't. After the boom, then the water went from the tire of the car to the second floor so fast. I think they blew the levees and they redirected the water from downtown.
然后突然我们听到了一声巨响，就像窗户被吸出来一样。现在，我们都贴了胶带什么的，所以它们只是想炸开，但没成功。巨响之后，水位从车轮迅速涨到了二楼。我认为他们炸毁了大堤，并引导了市中心的水流。
In the last decade, there's been a ton of investigation into what caused this boom and what blew up the levees. The big official investigations did not find evidence of dynamite or of anybody blowing up the levees on purpose. So the question is, what made the boom?
在过去的十年里，已经进行了大量的调查，调查是什么导致了这声巨响以及什么炸毁了大堤。大型官方调查没有发现炸药的证据，也没有发现任何人故意炸毁大堤的证据。所以问题是，是什么制造了巨响？
Well, the consensus is that it was not one boom. There were lots of booms coming from a few different sources, like, for instance, when the levee on the north side of the Lower Ninth Ward cracked and toppled over at 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning of the storm. That would've made a huge boom, like a thick branch snapping in half, and then water would have rushed in. Other booms came from electrical transformers blowing up and from a massive barge that banged against the Industrial Canal levee later that morning, like somebody beating on a huge, empty steel trashcan one expert told me, till it came over the levee and landed in the Lower Ninth.
嗯，共识是那不是一声巨响。有许多来自不同来源的巨响，例如，当飓风当天凌晨4点或5点，下九区北侧的大堤裂开并倒塌时。那会制造巨大的巨响，像一根粗树枝折断，然后水就会涌进来。其他的巨响来自电力变压器爆炸，以及当天晚些时候一艘巨大的驳船撞击工业运河大堤，就像有人在敲击一个巨大的空钢垃圾桶，一位专家告诉我，直到它越过大堤落入下九区。
But it's also clear that people aren't crazy to believe the levees were dynamited by the government. They believe that for some very good reasons. For starters, the government's done it before.
但同样清楚的是，人们相信大堤被政府炸毁并非疯了。他们相信这一点是有充分理由的。首先，政府以前干过这种事。
It is very real. It very much happened. And you combine that with the sound of the boom, and it's not surprising that that theory has life.
这是非常真实的。它确实发生了。加上那种爆炸声，难怪那个理论能一直流传。
John Barry has served on the levee board responsible for protecting New Orleans, the Southeast Louisiana Flood Protection Authority East. But he's a journalist. And before that, he wrote a great book called Rising Tide , about the 1927 flood that caused more devastation than Katrina did and that led city officials to decide that they were going to save downtown New Orleans by blowing up the levees in an area where poor people lived, a spot that's just a 20-minute drive from the Lower Ninth. All this with the consent of the governor, federal government, and the president.
John Barry曾在负责保护新奥尔良的大堤委员会——东南路易斯安那防洪管理局东部——任职。但他也是一名记者。在此之前，他写了一本很棒的书叫《Rising Tide》，讲述了1927年的洪水，那场洪水造成的破坏比卡特里娜飓风还要严重，导致城市官员决定通过炸毁穷人居住区的堤坝来挽救新奥尔良市中心，那个地方距离下九区只有20分钟车程。所有这一切都是在州长、联邦政府和总统的同意下进行的。
They had to promise to pay for reparations to everyone who was damaged. 95% of the people who ended up being flooded out by this dynamiting were white. But they had no political power. Many of them didn't speak English. They spoke an 18th century Spanish. They were referred to as Islenos. Most of them came from the Canary Islands. And it was dynamited.
他们不得不承诺向所有受损者支付赔偿。95%最终被炸毁洪水淹没的人是白人。但他们没有政治权力。他们中许多人不会说英语。他们说的是一种18世纪的西班牙语。他们被称为Islenos。他们大多数来自加那利群岛。它被炸毁了。
And it was kind of hard to do, right?
这很难做到，对吧？
It was very difficult to do. That was a very good levee.
这非常困难。那是一个非常好的大堤。
They just had to keep going back and blowing it up again and again.
他们只是不得不回去一次又一次地炸它。
That's correct.
没错。
How many people were displaced?
有多少人流离失所？
Roughly 10,000.
大约10000人。
And did the government pay reparations?
政府支付赔偿了吗？
Well, it was the city of New Orleans that was supposed to pay the reparations. And the city pretty much stiffed everyone who they had made promises to.
嗯，应该是新奥尔良市政府支付赔偿。政府基本上欺骗了所有他们做出过承诺的人。
There's another good reason that people believe that the government wanted them out and blew up the levees to do it. Gwen Adams, who you heard at the beginning of the show, talked to me about this. It's a more immediate reason, a more personal reason.
人们相信政府想让他们离开并炸毁大堤来实现这一目标的另一个好理由是。节目开头提到的Gwen Adams和我谈过这个。这是一个更直接的理由，一个更个人的理由。
It's so believable, because when people were interested in coming back to see what they needed to do in order to rebuild, they said, you can't do that, because we're going to green space this area. We wanted to come back and see what our property looked like. They held us off at gunpoint. When you attempted to get permits to rebuild, they fought you tooth and nail at City Hall with permitting for every little thing.
这太可信了，因为当人们有兴趣回来看看他们需要做什么来重建时，他们说，你们不能这样做，因为我们要把这个区域变成绿地。我们想回来看看我们的财产是什么样子的。他们用枪指着我们不让靠近。当你试图获得重建许可时，他们在市政厅为了每一件小事的审批和你斗得你死我活。
FEMA housing money was distributed with a formula that made it harder for families in the Lower Ninth to rebuild. City services, running water, schools arrived so much later in the Lower Ninth. In other words, it's the things that the city and state did after the flood that made the idea that the government just wanted everybody out, and it might have blown up the levees to achieve that, seem so very credible.
联邦住房资金的分配公式使得下九区的家庭更难重建。城市服务、自来水、学校在下九区出现得晚得多。换句话说，正是市政府和州政府在洪水后所做的事情，让政府只是想让大家离开，并且可能已经炸毁大堤来实现这一目标的想法显得如此可信。
Well, we have arrived at the fourth stop on our tour, a little block called El Dorado. It just has a handful of houses on it. Face north on this block, and you see an empty lot that is overgrown and smelly. And if you turn and face south, you see two nicely rebuilt, bright blue houses.
好吧，我们已经到达了行程的第四站，一个叫埃尔多拉多的街区。上面只有几栋房子。在这个街区向北看，你可以看到一个杂草丛生、臭气熏天的空地。如果你转身向南看，你会看到两栋重新修建的、亮蓝色的房子。
How you doing?
你好吗？
Good. How you doing?
很好。你好吗？
I'm good.
我很好。
When Zoe, from our program, happened upon this street, this guy, Roy Bradley, called out to her from his porch.
当来自我们节目的Zoe偶然来到这条街时，这个叫Roy Bradley的人从他的门廊上喊住了她。
You were the first house?
你是第一栋回来的房子？
Said he was the first house back on the block. And now they were trying to take his house. Come up, he said.
他说他是这个街区第一个回来的。现在他们正试图拿走他的房子。上来吧，他说。
Come on up.
上来吧。
OK. I'm a radio reporter.
好的。我是广播记者。
OK.
好的。
So I have a microphone [INAUDIBLE].
所以我有个麦克风（听不清）。
That's fine. What I'm going through, I need all the something.
没关系。我正在经历的这些，我需要所有的帮助。
No, I can tell.
不，我看得出来。
It's a-- it's a--
这……这……
I can tell.
我看得出来。
Just saying.
只是说说。
You're like, bring that microphone over here.
你就像，把麦克风拿到这儿来。
Please.
请吧。
Roy was dressed for football season, though it was still summer-- a New Orleans Saints shirt, Saints hat, Saints slippers, Saints socks. Zoe stuck around to get to know him a little bit.
Roy穿着橄榄球赛季的衣服，尽管还是夏天——一件新奥尔良圣徒队的衬衫、圣徒队的帽子、圣徒队的拖鞋、圣徒队的袜子。Zoe留下来多了解了他一点。
Roy's 46, and he's lived in the Lower Ninth for 46 years. Right away, he takes me around the corner to his mom's house, which there's no house. It's an empty green lawn with a square of sidewalk in front. 23 years ago, Roy's family all came outside and wrote their names in wet cement.
Roy 46岁了，在下九区住了46年。他立刻带我到拐角处看他妈妈的房子，那儿已经没有房子了。那是一块空的绿地，前面有一块人行道。23年前，Roy的家人都出来，在湿水泥里刻下了他们的名字。
This is my sister Veronica, my sister Kesie. That's my wife, Danielle, right there. And they call me Boo Boo. They call me Boo. So this is me here. Man, this is still here.
这是我姐姐Veronica，姐姐Kesie。那是我的妻子Danielle。他们管我叫Boo Boo。他们叫我Boo。所以我在这里。天哪，这个还在。
Big man, that's my daddy. Oh, Betty-- that's my other sister. Samantha-- we call her Betty.
大个子，那是我老爸。噢，Betty——那是我另一个姐姐。Samantha——我们叫她Betty。
How many of these people still live in New Orleans.
这些人中有多少人还住在新奥尔良？
Um, me. [LAUGHS]
嗯，我。（笑）
Kesie's in Slidell. Veronica's in Mobile. And on and on. Roy is the only one back. He has two houses here in the Lower Nine, bright blue, right next to each other. It was a big deal when he and his wife bought them-- 2001, not long before Katrina.
Kesie在Slidell。Veronica在莫比尔。诸如此类。Roy是唯一回来的人。他在这里有两栋房子，亮蓝色，就在彼此旁边。他和妻子买下它们时是一件大事——2001年，就在卡特里娜飓风前不久。
This was Roy's life plan, a classic life plan. Pay down the mortgage on both houses by renting out one of them. He worked two jobs, still does. He cooks at Mizado's at night and at TGI Friday's during the day. Once the mortgage was paid off, he and his wife Danielle would buy another place and rent out the starter homes to pay off that one.
这就是Roy的人生计划，经典的人生计划。通过出租其中一栋来付清两栋房子的抵押贷款。他打两份工，现在还在打。他晚上在Mizado's做饭，白天在TGI Friday's。抵押贷款一旦付清，他和妻子Danielle就会买另一个地方，然后出租初始的房子来还清那个贷款。
These houses would help us pay for the next house, or the next step. And then after we pay that off, we would be into something else. And maybe I could open me a restaurant. And I wouldn't have to work so much in my own place. Me and my wife could open her beauty salon.
这些房子会帮我们付下一栋房子的钱，或者下一阶段的钱。然后在付清之后，我们会转向别的事情。也许我可以开一家餐馆。我不需要在自己的店里工作得那么辛苦。我和我妻子可以开她的美容院。
Danielle jumps in here.
Danielle插话道。
You see, we crawl before we walk.
你看，我们先学会爬，再学会走。
Crawl before you walk.
先爬再走。
So we don't have to come back to crawling.
这样我们就不用回到爬行的状态了。
That was the plan, before the storm. When the storm did hit, Roy left town on the advice of his favorite weatherman, Bob Breck.
这就是那个计划，在飓风之前。当飓风来袭时，Roy听从了他最喜欢的气象学家Bob Breck的建议离开了城市。
I'd been listening to Bob Breck since I was a child on Channel 8 weather. Bob Breck, he--
我从小就开始听Bob Breck在8频道预报天气。Bob Breck，他——
You trusted him.
你信任他。
He was on it, man. He was there all night. And he just was saying, please, go. Please, please, whatever you do. And that's when I just said, you know what? I'm going to go.
他在现场，伙计。他整晚都在那儿。他只是说，求你了，走吧。求你了，无论你怎么做。那就是我对自己说，你知道吗？我要走了。
Did you see some of your neighbors when you were driving out? And you were like, yo, let's go.
你开车离开时看到你的邻居了吗？你有没说，嘿，我们也走吧。
Oh, I seen a couple of them, man. And my neighbor at this corner here, at Gordon and El Dorado, he was washing the car. And he was washing the car. He was cleaning out the drains at the corner there, because we used to do that before the storm.
噢，我看到了几个，伙计。我在戈登街和埃尔多拉多街的路口看到我邻居正在洗车。他正在洗车。他正在清理街角的排水沟，因为我们在飓风前常那么做。
And I was like, man, you ain't leaving? You ain't going nowhere? Man, I ain't going. I ain't worried about no storm. You know how we do around here. And that actually was the last time I seen him. He didn't make it through. Wanda, his wife, told me that he drowned, that they was on top of the roof. And he had drowned before they got to the roof.
我就说，伙计，你不走吗？你哪儿也不去？伙计，我不走。我不担心什么飓风。你知道我们这里是怎么做的。那实际上是我最后一次见到他。他没挺过来。他的妻子Wanda告诉我他溺水了，当时他们都在屋顶上。在他们到达屋顶之前他就溺水了。
Roy estimates the number of neighbors he lost in the storm around 14. As we walk, he points out their houses, or where their houses were. There was a guy across the street who died right after the storm. He was running a generator, and his house burned up.
Roy估计他在飓风中失去了大约14个邻居。在我们走路时，他指出他们的房子，或者他们曾经房子所在的位置。街对面有个家伙在飓风后不久就去世了。他开着发电机，结果房子起火了。
He died, and burned in the house.
他死了，在房子里烧死了。
The son of Danielle's pastor died, Roy says, when his house was dragged a few blocks away. The roofs here were filled with people during the storm. One of his neighbors even swam to Roy's house to look for him.
Roy说，Danielle牧师的儿子去世了，当时他的房子被冲到了几个街区外。飓风期间，这里的屋顶上挤满了人。其中一个邻居甚至游到Roy的房子去找他。
It took months before he was even allowed back onto this block. He had to show ID at the bridge. And then the National Guard gave him 30 minutes. You already know the house was totaled. Everything they had was gone.
过了几个月他才获准回到这个街区。他必须在桥上出示身份证。然后国民警卫队给了他30分钟。你已经知道房子全毁了。他们拥有的一切都没了。
My wife cried. She cried the whole time we was in the house. I thought it was gonna flood all over again in the house. [LAUGHS] I said, baby, you've got to stop.
我妻子哭了。我们在屋里的时候她一直在哭。我以为房子又要被淹了。（笑）我说，宝贝，你得停下。
You didn't cry?
你没哭？
Well, seeing her cry, I might have dropped a tear or two. But I-- you know. [LAUGHS] Women, you know?
嗯，看到她哭，我可能也掉了一两滴眼泪。但我……你知道的。（笑）女人，你知道吧？
He'll cry, though. He cried for an hour the night the Saints won the Super Bowl. Next, for Roy, the familiar beats of Katrina keep going -- 13 hour car ride to Baton Rouge, a year in Atlanta, then back to New Orleans and a FEMA trailer. No stores, no lights, nobody, no one around.
他确实会哭，不过。圣徒队赢得超级碗那天晚上他哭了一个小时。接下来，对Roy来说，卡特里娜飓风的熟悉节奏在继续——13小时车程去巴吞鲁日，在亚特兰大待了一年，然后回到新奥尔良，住进联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的拖车。没有商店，没有灯，没有别人，周围一个人也没有。
They got a little FEMA money, a little insurance money, and a whole bunch of free help from this nonprofit who set up shop right next to Roy's broken down home, lowernine.org. Two years after the storm, the family moved back in.
他们得到了一点FEMA资金，一点保险金，还有从一家在Roy破败的家旁边设立办事处的非营利组织lowernine.org那里得到的许多免费帮助。飓风两年后，这家人搬了回来。
So picture right at this point in the story, it was like Roy was back where he was when he first bought his houses. It was a reset. Start at the bottom and climb back up. And this is the moment when Roy makes this totally fateful decision. He decides to take out a loan to borrow some money, fix up the other little house, which was a shell after Katrina; it was dry rotting, so he could start renting it again.
所以，在这个故事的这一点上，你可以想象，Roy回到了他第一次买房子时的地方。这是一个重置。从底部开始，重新往上爬。就在这时，Roy做了一个彻底改变命运的决定。他决定贷款借钱，修理另一栋小房子，那栋在飓风后是一个空壳；因为干腐，他想修理它，这样就可以重新出租。
I put it on Facebook. That's what I did.
我把它发到了Facebook上。我就是那么做的。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
I put it on Facebook. I'm trying to get a loan. Anyone knows someone that they can suggest to me to go to to get a loan. You get all these people, oh, yeah, yeah, [MUMBLING]. So that's when I went on to Loan Partners and took out the loan.
我发在Facebook上。我正在设法贷款。任何人认识可以推荐给我去贷款的人吗。你得到了所有人，噢，是的，是的（含糊不清）。那就是我找到Loan Partners并贷款的时候。
Loan Partners.
Loan Partners。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
Loan Partners, the kind of company that made a lot of loans after Katrina to help with construction and rebuilding. And they lent Roy money for exactly that, to rebuild his rental property-- $60,000. But this was nothing like a typical mortgage loan. It had a very short deadline-- one year-- less, actually-- 11 months.
Loan Partners，就是那种在卡特里娜飓风后发放了大量贷款以帮助建设和重建的公司。他们借钱给Roy正是为了这个，重建他的出租房产——6万美元。但这和典型的抵押贷款完全不同。它有一个非常短的期限——一年——实际上更短——11个月。
And it worked like this. For a year, you just pay interest every month. At the end, you pay off the whole thing, the original $60,000, all at once. I asked to see a copy. The rate seems high, 12 and 1/2%. And there are all sorts of hikes in fees that kick in if you're delinquent.
它的运作方式是这样的。一年里，你每个月只付利息。最后，你一次性付清全部金额，原始的6万美元。我要求看一份复印件。利率看起来很高，12.5%。如果你违约，还有各种各样的费用会上涨。
I didn't read all that.
我没读完那些。
These are really hard terms.
这些条件真的非常苛刻。
And I signed it.
我还是签了。
Without really reading it.
没怎么读。
I didn't.
我没读。
Because why? You kind of trusted your friend, and they were like, this is a good company.
因为为什么？你有点信任你的朋友，而且他们说，这是一家好公司。
Right. That, and just to get my house fixed. That was my main goal is to get myself back on track to where I was before the storm hit.
对。那个，还有就是为了修好我的房子。这是我的主要目标，让我回到飓风来袭前的轨道上。
The only reason Roy was able to get this loan in the first place was because after Katrina, the government was handing out checks to homeowners to rebuild their houses. Loan Partners knew Roy would qualify for a bunch of this money as soon as he fixed up his rental property. And Roy did qualify. And the money did come.
Roy最初之所以能拿到这笔贷款，是因为在卡特里娜飓风后，政府正在给房主支票来重建房屋。Loan Partners知道Roy一旦修好他的出租房产，就有资格获得一大笔这笔钱。Roy确实有资格。钱也确实到了。
But instead of paying off the loan all at once, he just kept sending those monthly payments. He thought it was like a mortgage, like the mortgages he'd been paying for years before the storm. Ray found out how big a mistake he'd made when he came home and he found this sign on his house.
但他没有一次性付清贷款，而是继续寄送那些月供。他以为这就像抵押贷款，就像飓风前他多年来一直支付的那些一样。Roy发现他犯了多大的错误，是在他回家发现房子上有这个标志的时候。
Can you read what it says?
你能读读上面写什么吗？
"Five day notice to vacate the premises. First Civil Court of New Orleans states, February the 12th, 2015. Occupants--" I don't know when I became occupant in my house. "Owner wants possession." When have you became the owner? From Loan Partners?
“五天内腾出房屋的通知。新奥尔良第一民事法院声明，2015年2月12日。占用者——”我不知道我什么时候成了我房子里的占用者。“所有者要求占有。”你什么时候成了所有者？从Loan Partners那里？
Here's the thing. Loan Partners does own Roy's house now-- both his houses. Roy didn't pay off his loan. The houses went into foreclosure, and Loan Partners got them. Roy and Danielle can't really believe this. They're challenging it in court and appealing the sale.
情况是这样的。Loan Partners现在确实拥有Roy的房子——他的两栋房子。Roy没有付清贷款。房子被取消了抵押品赎回权，Loan Partners拿到了房子。Roy和Danielle真的无法相信。他们正在法庭上提出异议并上诉。
I talked to one of the guys at Loan Partners, Bob Bergeron. He said, no, their business isn't built through squeezing people through tough terms and then taking their property. Most of the people they've lent money to haven't defaulted, he says. And that seems to check out.
我和Loan Partners的一个人Bob Bergeron谈过。他说，不，他们的生意不是建立在通过严苛的条件压榨人们然后拿走他们的财产之上的。他说，大多数借款给他们的人并没有违约。看起来确实如此。
It's not such an unusual loan for a professional real estate investor. But it is for Roy, who is so far from where he thought he'd be at this moment-- close to losing his home for the second time in 10 years.
对于职业房地产投资者来说，这并不是什么罕见的贷款。但对于Roy来说，这让他远低于他此刻预期的位置——10年内第二次接近失去家园。
To say that it's been 10 years, it should be better. You know, it's like I'm trying to get it back together, and now I'm back like I'm going back down this road. Then 10 years later, I shouldn't be there. I should be stepping to another step in life.
说已经过去10年了，情况本该好转的。你知道，就像我试图把一切拼凑起来，现在我又回到了原来的道路上。10年后，我不该出现在这里。我应该进入生活的另一个阶段。
There are so many lots for sale in the Lower Ninth Ward since the storm. And in Roy's neighborhood, people are buying them up, building new houses, then turning them around and selling them for a couple hundred thousand dollars just down the street from him. It's a fortune compared to what Roy paid 15 years ago.
自飓风以来，下九区有太多的空地在售。在Roy的社区，人们正买下它们，盖新房子，然后转手以比他那里高出几十万美元的价格卖出。与Roy 15年前支付的价格相比，这简直是一笔财富。
What do you think the neighborhood will be like in 10 years?
你认为10年后这里会是什么样？
10 more years? Oh, all of us will be gone. Black homeowners, we'll be out of here. 10 more years-- this is just my theory of it-- they're going to be done kicked all of us out of here. And they're going to have these nice, big, pretty houses back here. You're going to have the street car come down through the middle.
再过10年？噢，我们都将消失。黑人房主，我们会离开这里。再过10年——这只是我的看法——他们将把我们所有人都赶出去。他们会在这里盖起漂亮、宽敞、精美的房子。你会看到街车穿过中间。
And they're going to have the [INAUDIBLE] thing in the back on the levee. And then we'll be gone for good. I hope not, because I hope to still be here.
他们会在后面大堤上盖上（听不清）的东西。然后我们将彻底消失。我希望不是这样，因为我希望依然留在这里。
Roy's original plan was to buy properties in the Lower Ninth and rent them out to pay for his home. With the neighborhood booming, that's exactly what's happening-- for other people.
Roy最初的计划是在下九区购买房产并出租以支付他房子的费用。随着社区蓬勃发展，这正是正在发生的事情——但对其他人来说。
Zoe Chace.
Zoe Chace报道。
OK. We are at the fifth stop in our tour of the Lower Ninth, Royal Street. So you get on Royal Street and go as far east as it goes. Stop where it dead ends by that six-foot-high chain link fence. And as you stand here facing east, you can look through the fence and-- do that now-- you see the remains of the Holy Cross school. And you can see it was once a beautiful old southern school, three stories with columns and balconies and curved brick work, now left here basically to rot.
好吧。我们到达了下九区行程的第五站，皇家街。所以你走上皇家街一直向东走到尽头。停在那道6英尺高的链条栅栏边。当你站在这里面向东方时，你可以透过栅栏看——现在就做吧——你可以看到圣十字学校的遗迹。你可以看到它曾经是一所美丽的古老南方学校，三层楼高，有柱子、阳台和弧形砖墙，现在基本就在这里腐烂。
Look. The windows are boarded up. And there's a bright blue tarp on the roof that's ripping into shreds it's been up there so long. There's some kind of scary looking black mold that I think I see peeking through the bricks.
看。窗户被木板钉死了。屋顶上有一块亮蓝色的防水布，已经在上面太久了，正撕裂成碎片。我以为我看到砖缝里渗出某种看起来很可怕的黑霉。
What you're looking at right now, believe it or not, is the site of one of the big gentrification fights in the Lower Ninth. This last year, a developer has been trying to build an upscale high-rise here-- condos, seven stories tall, hundreds of apartments and offices, a huge parking lot-- in a neighborhood-- again, look around. It's almost entirely family houses just one or two stories tall. And whether or not this gets built, newcomers are moving into this area, especially this part of the ward.
信不信由你，你现在所看到的是下九区高档化斗争的中心之一。去年，一位开发商一直试图在这里建造一座高档高层建筑——公寓，七层楼高，数百间公寓和办公室，一个巨大的停车场——在一个街区里——再看一遍。几乎全是只有一两层楼高的家庭住房。无论这栋建筑是否建成，新人正搬进这个区域，特别是该区这一部分。
You remember Kirk Washington? Remember him, from the beginning of the show? He lives just a couple blocks from here. And across the street from him, a white couple moved in in his friend Isaac's old house. And he likes them. He likes them a lot, says hello.
还记得Kirk Washington吗？还记得节目开始提到的他吗？他就住在离这里几个街区的地方。在他对面，一对白人夫妇搬进了他朋友Isaac的老房子。他喜欢他们。他很喜欢他们，会打招呼。
How you doing?
你好吗？
Doing fine.
挺好的。
Hey, Mr. Wash, how are you doing?
嘿，Wash先生，你好吗？
I'm fine.
我很好。
All right.
好的。
That's the house that Isaac-- he drowned right there in that house right there.
那是Isaac的房子——他在那栋房子里溺水了。
The couple going into the house are Simon Hand and his wife, Sarah DeBacher. She's active in the local neighborhood association, and popular enough that they elected her vice president, and then they elected her president. But it's complicated being, you know, sort of the face of the changing Lower Ninth. One of our producers, Sean Cole, talked to Sarah.
搬进那栋房子的是Simon Hand和他的妻子Sarah DeBacher。她积极参与当地的社区协会，受欢迎程度以至于他们选她做副主席，然后选她做主席。但作为一个，你知道，某种程度上代表下九区变革的人，情况是很复杂的。我们的一位制作人Sean Cole采访了Sarah。
Even though she thinks about race-- her race-- all the time, Sarah DeBacher is still figuring out how to talk about it. She can have a hard time getting through a sentence without stopping to comment on what she's saying, like when I asked her why she moved to Lower Ninth Ward after the storm.
尽管她一直在思考种族——她的种族——问题，Sarah DeBacher仍在弄清楚如何谈论它。她很难在不停止评论自己所说内容的情况下完整说出一个句子，就像当我问她为什么在飓风后搬到下九区时一样。
Maybe some of it had to do with guilt and wanting-- god, this is sounding gross-- wanting to be part of helping in a meaningful way to rebuild.
也许其中一些与内疚有关，想要——天哪，这听起来太恶心了——想要以一种有意义的方式参与重建。
Which, on the one hand, is noble, of course. But on the other hand, in helping to rebuild a neighborhood that was 88% black before the hurricane, Sarah's worried she'll come across as some white savior asshole.
一方面，这当然是高尚的。但另一方面，在重建一个飓风前88%是黑人的社区的过程中，Sarah担心自己会显得像个白人救世主混蛋。
My role as ah, I don't even want to say "my role." Who I am as a white newcomer to the Lower Ninth Ward, that identity has been an uncomfortable one for me.
作为一个搬进下九区的白人，我的角色——啊，我甚至不想说“我的角色”。我是谁——那个身份对我来说一直很不舒服。
"Newcomer" should probably be in quotes. Sarah's lived in the Lower Ninth Ward since 2008, so about three years after the hurricane. Before that, Sarah and Simon were living upriver from the Lower Ninth in the Marigny neighborhood, next to the French Quarter. But when they decided to buy a house, the Marigny wasn't an option. Because after Katrina, it was suddenly totally unaffordable for them.
“新人”可能应该加引号。Sarah自2008年起就住在下九区，也就是飓风后大约三年。在那之前，Sarah和Simon住在下九区上游的Marigny社区，靠近法国区。但当他们决定买房时，Marigny已经不在他们的考虑范围内了。因为卡特里娜飓风后，那里对他们来说突然变得完全负担不起了。
Katrina had a gentrifying effect on a lot of the city. First came the YURPS, or Young Urban Rebuilding Professionals. And after they helped put the city back together, another wave of entrepreneurs and tech workers and creative economy types came in. Sarah and Simon are both teachers. And the Lower Ninth Ward was more in their price range. Besides which, they liked it there.
卡特里娜飓风对城市的许多地方产生了高档化的影响。首先是YURPS，即“年轻城市重建专业人士”。在他们帮助城市恢复原貌后，另一波企业家、科技工作者和创意经济类型的人涌入。Sarah和Simon都是老师。下九区更符合他们的预算范围。除此之外，他们喜欢那里。
I don't want to romanticize some of the, like, "oh, because neighbors talk to each other." But I mean, that's part of it.
我不想浪漫化其中的一些，比如，“噢，因为邻居们会互相对话”。但我的意思是，那是其中的一部分。
They actually started going to community meetings even before they moved to the Lower Ninth Ward. And ultimately, they bought a $50,000 double shotgun house, financed by an FHA loan for first-time homebuyers, and knocked out the middle wall that separated the two apartments.
他们实际上甚至在搬进下九区之前就开始参加社区会议了。最终，他们以5万美元买下了一栋双层“猎枪房”，由联邦住房管理局（FHA）为首次购房者提供的贷款资助，并拆掉了分隔两间公寓的中间墙。
As you're more than aware by now, people in the Lower Ninth Ward are friendly. And they were friendly to Sarah and her husband. But there was definitely a "what are you doing here" type vibe in the beginning, and even a few years in. She remembers this one night after her first son was born. It was late, maybe 11 o'clock. And these kids down the way started setting off fireworks.
就像你现在已经非常清楚的那样，下九区的人们很友好。他们对Sarah和她丈夫也很友好。但刚开始，甚至几年后，确实有一种“你们在这儿干什么”的氛围。她记得她第一个儿子出生后的那个晚上。很晚了，也许11点。远处那些孩子开始放烟花。
And my son had colic. And so, like, I was in the trenches with this baby who never stopped crying. And he was asleep. And then these fireworks started going off. And I went out in and first talked to the kids and just said, "hey, can you maybe do that another time?"
我儿子有绞痛。所以，我就像陷入了苦战，带着一个不停哭闹的婴儿。他好不容易睡着了。然后烟花开始放了。我走出去，先和孩子们谈，只是说，“嘿，你们能不能换个时间做这个？”
And then there was a voice from the porch. And she was like, if you have a problem, you can talk to me. You don't talk to my kids. And, you know, touche.
然后门廊上传来一个声音。她说，如果你有问题，你可以跟我谈。别动我的孩子。你说得对，touché。
That's fair.
这很公平。
So Sarah says to her, look, you're a mom. I'm a mom. I've got this colicky baby. I'm going nuts. Can you please tell your kids to knock it off?
所以Sarah对她说，看，你是个妈妈。我也是个妈妈。我有这个绞痛的宝宝。我快疯了。你能请告诉你的孩子们停下吗？
And she came off the porch and got in my face and said, you know, we didn't have any problems before you people moved in. We all minded our own business. And I was like, whoa. I really just need to sleep. I need just my baby to sleep. That's what this is about.
她走下门廊，走到我面前说，你知道吗，在你们这些家伙搬进来之前我们没有任何问题。我们都各管各的。我当时想，哇。我真的只是想睡觉。我只是需要我的宝宝睡觉。这就是事情的真相。
And she just wasn't hearing it. I mean, she was not hearing it. That conversation was about the changes in her neighborhood and anger about that. And at that moment, I was trying to make it about me. You know, like, can we be neighbors?
她根本听不进去。我的意思是，她根本听不进去。那次对话是关于她社区的变化以及对此的愤怒。在那一刻，我试图把它变成我自己的问题。你知道，比如，我们能做邻居吗？
And I don't know. When I'm thinking about it now, I'm realizing that maybe my expectation that I would be able to diffuse that situation was coming from a little bit of a sense of entitlement. Like, why aren't you calming down?
我不知道。当我回想起来，我意识到也许我能够平息那种局面的期望，是来自一种权利感。就像，为什么你不能冷静下来？
Right.
对。
But I recognize that that interaction was tied to who I am-- big W--
但我承认那种互动是和我这个人有关的——大写的W——
Big W White person. But it's not just that Sarah's a white person in the Lower Ninth Ward. She's a community leader. When that interaction with her neighbor happened, Sarah was already vice president of her neighborhood association. And it's tricky to work on behalf of this largely African American community in a way that doesn't seem like she's saying, I know what's good for you.
大写的白人。但不仅仅是因为Sarah是住在下九区的白人。她是一位社区领袖。当那种与邻居的互动发生时，Sarah已经是社区协会的副主席了。以一种似乎她是在说“我知道什么对你们好”的方式代表这个主要是非裔美国人的社区工作，是很棘手的。
Good afternoon, and thank you for coming. The public hearing before the city planning commission is now called to order.
下午好，谢谢你们的到来。城市规划委员会之前的听证会现在开始。
But this is how skewed and confusing the politics can get. That big condo complex that's been proposed in the Lower Ninth Ward? Sarah is one of the people spearheading the opposition to it. At a planning commission meeting last year, her neighbors applauded her before she even started talking. She cited specific zoning ordinances and showed slides.
但这就是政治可能会变得多么扭曲和混乱。那个在下九区提议的大型公寓群？Sarah是带头反对它的人之一。在去年的一次规划委员会会议上，她的邻居在她还没开口前就为她鼓掌。她列举了具体的区划条例并展示了幻灯片。
I've been hearing again and again that the Lower Ninth Ward has to take what they can get. We do not believe that the Lower Ninth Ward has to take what we can get. In fact--
我一次又一次地听到下九区必须接受他们能得到的东西。我们不相信下九区必须接受我们能得到的东西。事实上——
But then one of the supporters of the project stood up, a guy who said he was born in the Lower Ninth and was around for Hurricane Betsy too, and that the area really needs a development like this one. And then he basically said the thing that Sarah's so concerned about all the time.
但随后项目的一位支持者站了起来，一个声称他出生在下九区并也经历过贝特西飓风的人，说该地区确实需要像这样的开发项目。然后他基本上说了Sarah一直担心的那件事。
And you Johnny-come-lately people, y'all don't know about the Lower Ninth Ward. Y'all don't know anything about the Lower Ninth Ward.
而你们这些后来者，你们根本不懂下九区。你们对下九区一无所知。
So for understandable reasons, Sarah wants to make sure she's being a neighbor in the right way. And she's actually checked in with folks, in a way that you never really encounter, to ask them point blank, am I doing this the right way?
所以，出于可以理解的原因，Sarah想确保她以正确的方式成为邻居。她实际上以一种你从未真正遇到过的方式询问过人们，直截了当地问，我这样做对吗？
You know, I came home last night and talked to a couple of my neighbors, Trina and Duane, about, like, what does this feel like for you, this 10 years later stuff? And how are you doing? And I was like, so what did you think when we moved here? What did you think? And Trina said, well, you know, Bud wanted to buy that house.
你知道，我昨晚回家和我的几个邻居Trina和Duane谈过，关于，你们对此有什么感觉，这些10年后的事情？你们过得怎么样？我当时问，那么我们搬到这里时你们怎么想？你们怎么想？Trina说，嗯，你知道，Bud想买那栋房子。
Bud is Kirk Washington. Some people call him Bud. They also call him Wash and Washington. He has a lot of names.
Bud就是Kirk Washington。有些人叫他Bud。他们也叫他Wash和Washington。他有很多名字。
And he just, I guess, didn't get it together in time or whatever. And so there was that. But we don't have a problem with you, Sarah, We don't have a problem with you. Which was interesting, because the implication there is that there are problems. Because there are.
我想他没来得及准备好还是怎么着。所以就是那样。但我们和你没问题，Sarah，我们和你没问题。这很有趣，因为其中暗示了存在问题。因为确实存在。
Do you feel like you're a part of the problem?
你觉得你是问题的一部分吗？
I don't know, man. In some ways, I don't feel like I really have control over that. That's a good question, right? But in some ways, I feel like, well, so what if I do or don't?
我不知道，伙计。在某些方面，我觉得我并没有真正控制这一点。这是个好问题，对吧？但在某些方面，我觉得，嗯，那么如果我是或不是又怎样？
It's really up to the people around her to make that call. And it's up to them whether to hold it against her that she wouldn't even be their neighbor if it weren't for this storm that upended all their lives.
这真的要由她周围的人来决定。至于他们是否因为如果不是这场改变了他们所有人生活的风暴，她根本不会成为他们的邻居而记恨她，那取决于他们。
My neighbor told me last night that the man who lived in our house-- and I knew this. I knew that someone had died in our house, although I didn't know when we bought the house. I really didn't. I mean, like, how naive can I be? It said one DOA, like, spray painted on the side of the house.
我的邻居昨晚告诉我，那个住进我们房子的人——我知道这个。我知道有人死在我们的房子里，虽然我们在买房时不知道。真的不知道。我的意思是，我能有多天真？房子侧面喷漆写着一个DOA。
Dead on arrival.
死亡到达。
And then I went and talked to Washington. And Washington told me-- this is like why my neighbors are so dope, OK? So Washington told me the man who lived in our house that he had a bit of a drinking problem. And probably he just drank too much and fell asleep on the bed and the water just came up over his head. He told me that.
然后我去找了Washington。Washington告诉我——这就是为什么我的邻居们如此出色的原因，好吗？所以Washington告诉我说住进我们那栋房子的男人有点酗酒问题。很可能他只是喝得太多，在床上睡着了，水就漫过他的头顶。他告诉了我那个。
So just to clarify, this is what Kirk Washington said to Sarah at the time, seven years ago, when she first got to the neighborhood. He did not tell her what he told Robyn, about how his neighbor Isaac shouted for help and how he's haunted by that still.
所以澄清一下，这就是Kirk Washington七年前刚到社区时对Sarah所说的话。他并没有告诉她他告诉Robyn的那些内容，关于他的邻居Isaac如何呼救，以及他至今仍受此折磨。
And then last night, Trina told me the truth, which I'm not sure I can really utter without falling apart. But he didn't go quietly in his sleep.
然后昨晚，Trina告诉了我真相，我不确定我能不能在不崩溃的情况下说出来。但他不是在睡梦中平静离去的。
Even for people who weren't here for the storm, everything in the Lower Ninth Ward is attached to loss in some way. And the recovery has been so slow. And it's happening in a way that a lot of people here, including Sarah, didn't sign up for.
即使对于那些没经历过飓风的人来说，下九区的一切都在某种程度上与失去相连。复苏过程如此缓慢。而且它的发生方式是许多人，包括Sarah，并没有预料到的。
On the surface, it looks like the really typical story of gentrification. And as a country, we are terrible at that, at figuring out how to improve the neighborhood without fundamentally altering it and displacing the people who live there. There are always losers. But what's especially harsh here in the Lower Ninth is that this is happening in a place where so much loss has already come before it.
从表面上看，这看起来像是高档化非常典型的故事。作为一个国家，我们在处理这方面很糟糕，在弄清楚如何在不从根本上改变社区并流离失所现有居民的情况下改善社区方面很糟糕。总是有输家。但下九区特别严酷的是，这发生在一个此前已经承受了如此多失去的地方。
Sean Cole.
Sean Cole报道。
We've arrived at the sixth stop, our last stop, on the tour of the Lower Ninth.
我们到达了下九区行程的第六站，也是最后一站。
Morning. Come on, man. You got the ball.
早上好。来吧，伙计。球在你那儿。
On Alabo Street, between North Villere and Urquhart, there's some rebuilt homes. And there's some homes that look like Katrina just hit, like one house that scares the neighborhood kids that has possums living inside. In front of an abandoned lot, somebody's put up a basketball hoop.
在North Villere街和Urquhart街之间的Alabo街上，有一些重新修建的房屋。也有一些看起来像是刚被卡特里娜飓风摧毁的房屋，就像有一栋吓坏了社区孩子、里面住着负鼠的房子。在一个废弃的地块前面，有人放了一个篮球框。
And we talked to so many people in the Lower Ninth who are still so traumatized by what happened a decade ago that at some point, we just started looking for anybody who wasn't. That's how we ended up here.
我们和下九区的许多人谈过，他们对十年前发生的事情依然如此创伤，以至于在某种程度上，我们只是开始寻找任何没有创伤的人。这就是我们最后来到这里的原因。
When I think about it, I just turn on the TV--
当我想到这一点时，我只是打开电视——
You know what people do?
你知道人们做什么吗？
Shhh. I'm talking.
嘘。我在说话。
Come on, man.
来吧，伙计。
I just turn on the TV, do a search, and I type in Hurricane Season -- you know the movie that they made about New Orleans, yeah? I'll be watching that.
我只是打开电视，搜索，输入《Hurricane Season》——你知道他们拍的关于新奥尔良的电影吧？我就看那个。
Brishun Gary and his buddies talked to Zoe. They are 14, 13, and 11. And they do not remember the storm. Their big source of information, this film Hurricane Season , is a straight to DVD film about high school basketball players in the city after the storm. Needless to say, when these guys tell the story of the storm that destroyed their own neighborhood, it is without the pain you hear when adults tell it.
Brishun Gary和他的伙计们和Zoe谈了话。他们14、13和11岁。他们不记得飓风了。他们信息的主要来源，这部电影《Hurricane Season》，是一部关于飓风后城市高中篮球运动员的直发DVD电影。不用说，当这些家伙讲述摧毁他们自己社区的飓风故事时，那是不带成年人讲述时听到的痛苦的。
Because my grandmother was with that. They was living through that. She said they lying down. Next thing you know, all you hear was, ah, ah, swish.
因为我祖母经历过那个。他们经历了那个。她说他们躺着。接下来你知道的，你听到的全是，啊，啊，唰。
What?
什么？
And she said-- because they were screaming.
她说——因为他们在尖叫。
[GIGGLING]
（咯咯笑）
No, listen. Because they were screaming. And then she was like, swish. And then the water just came on [INAUDIBLE]. The roof came off. [GROWL] So she said she couldn't get on top of the roof, so she got on top of her dresser.
不，听着。因为他们在尖叫。然后她是这样，唰。然后水就漫过来了（听不清）。屋顶被掀开了。（咆哮）所以她说她爬不上屋顶，于是她爬上了她的梳妆台。
And once she told me that, I'm like, man. I thought she was lying at first. So I started watching movies. And then I was like, oh, yes, must be true.
一旦她告诉我这些，我就想，伙计。我起初以为她在撒谎。所以我开始看电影。然后我就想，噢，是的，那一定是真的。
What's interesting talking to kids about this is that some of the events that adults remember with horror, like being displaced to Texas or to Georgia, and all the difficulties in providing for their kids and finding housing and finding work, for the kids was sometimes just a very different experience.
和孩子们谈论这件事很有趣的是，成年人带着恐惧记忆的一些事件，比如流离失所到德克萨斯州或佐治亚州，以及在照顾孩子、寻找住房和寻找工作方面的所有困难，对孩子们来说有时只是完全不同的体验。
It was so fun.
太好玩了。
Breyana was only two when her family fled the city for Texas.
Breyana在家人逃离城市去德克萨斯时只有两岁。
Because I remember getting to spend time with my family. Because usually, you know your mom goes to work, and your grandma goes to work. And I was happy, because my mom and my grandma was at home, and we get to have fun with each other.
因为我记得我得到了和家人在一起的时间。因为通常，你知道你妈妈去上班，你祖母去上班。我很高兴，因为我妈妈和祖母在家，我们能在一起玩得很开心。
Like after Hurricane Katrina, we went from Mississippi, from Mississippi to Georgia, from Georgia to South Carolina, from South Carolina to North Carolina to North Carolina, Pennsylvania. I've been all over. [LAUGHS] I've been all over for real.
就像卡特里娜飓风后，我们去了密西西比，从密西西比去了佐治亚，从佐治亚去了南卡罗来纳，从南卡罗来纳去了北卡罗来纳，宾夕法尼亚。我到处都去过。（笑）我到处都去过，真的。
Bron was 12 when the storm hit and his family went all over.
Bron在飓风来袭时12岁，他的家人到处走。
It's pretty nice to actually see other states than just New Orleans. Because when I was young, I didn't used to see nothing else outside. Hurricane Katrina really helped me out to see other places. Yeah.
能看到新奥尔良以外的其他州真的挺不错的。因为当我小的时候，我过去什么都看不到。卡特里娜飓风真的帮我走出去看到了其他地方。是的。
Over on Gordon Street, between Burgundy and Rampart, Robyn ran into this 23-year-old, just, you know, on the street. And they started talking. And his name is Terrence Marshall. He went to Texas for a year after the storm. And then his family came back. And since then, he's found all of his old friends from when he was a little kid growing up here, from back when he was 13, except one of them.
在Burgundy街和Rampart街之间的戈登街上，Robyn在街上遇到了这个23岁的年轻人。他们开始聊天。他叫Terrence Marshall。飓风后他在德克萨斯州待了一年。然后他的家人回来了。从那时起，他找到了他小时候在这里长大的所有老朋友，从他13岁时算起，除了其中一个。
His name's Samuel. Samuel.
他叫Samuel。Samuel。
Have you tried to find him?
你试着找过他吗？
Yeah, I tried on Facebook and Myspace. I tried Twitter. I called his house phone. But the line was disconnected. I can't find him.
是的，我在Facebook和Myspace上试过。我试过Twitter。我打过他的座机。但电话线路断了。我找不到他。
You tried to ask other people who knew him?
你试过问其他认识他的人吗？
Yeah. They ain't seen him either. So I just hope ain't nothing happened to him.
是的。他们也没见过他。所以我只能希望他没出什么事。
But you don't know.
但你不知道。
I don't know. I just want to see him again.
我不知道。我只是想再见他一面。
Though most of the people who died in Katrina were elderly, many of those in their own homes, some kids died, too. The best estimates are 10 or 20 in New Orleans.
尽管卡特里娜飓风中死亡的大多数人是老人，许多人在自己的家中死亡，但也有孩子去世。新奥尔良最好的估计是10到20人。
Terrence is an adult now. When he last saw Samuel, they were both in middle school, both 13. They loved to play Game Boy and YuGiOh cards together. He asked Robyn that we would broadcast a message over the radio. Here it is.
Terrence现在是成年人了。当他最后一次见到Samuel时，他们都在上中学，都是13岁。他们喜欢一起玩Game Boy和YuGiOh卡片。他请求Robyn通过电台广播一条信息。就是这条。
Hey, old Sam, it's T. Tell me if you made it. Have you made it through Katrina? Some kind of way you hear this, let me know you're alive, you hear me? I seen everybody except you. Tyrone. I've seen Mo. I even seen B. But hey, just let me know if you're out there.
嘿，老Sam，我是T。告诉我你挺过来了没。你挺过卡特里娜飓风了吗？如果你能以某种方式听到这个，让我知道你还活着，你听到了吗？除了你，所有人都见到了。Tyrone。我见到Mo了。我甚至见到B了。但嘿，只要让我知道你还在外面。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话响声）
Hello?
喂？
Terrence, it's Robyn. Can you hear me?
Terrence，我是Robyn。你能听到吗？
Yeah, I hear you.
是的，我听到了。
Hey, I have someone here that wants to talk to you.
嘿，我有个人在这里想和你谈谈。
All right.
好的。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, what's up?
嘿，什么事？
Who is this?
是谁？
This is Samuel.
我是Samuel。
Man, you're lying.
伙计，你撒谎。
Nah.
没。
I swear to god, son. Hey, Sam, where you at? Sam, it's Terrence, son. Sam, it's Terrence, son.
我向上帝发誓，孩子。嘿，Sam，你在哪儿？Sam，我是Terrence，孩子。Sam，我是Terrence，孩子。
Yeah. What's up, man?
是的。什么事，伙计？
Damn, boy. Where the hell you been?
该死，男孩。你到底去哪儿了？
I've been to New Jersey. I've been to Arkansas.
我去过新泽西。我去过阿肯色。
Man, what's up, brah? I even seen Maurice, Tyrone, Jessica, all of them. [INAUDIBLE]. I thought you was dead, boy. I swear to God.
伙计，什么事，兄弟？我甚至见到Maurice、Tyrone、Jessica，他们所有人。（听不清）。我以为你死了，男孩。我向上帝发誓。
Yeah.
是的。
Man, what's up, for real? How your mom doing? How your brothers doing? What's up?
伙计，真的，什么事？你妈妈怎么样？你兄弟怎么样？怎么回事？
Like, they're doing good.
他们过得很好。
Yeah, so I'm still short, lil son.
是的，所以我依然很矮，小家伙。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
Yeah, exactly. I'm only like 5'6", son-- 5'5", 5'6", son.
是的，确实。我只有5英尺6英寸，孩子——5英尺5、5英尺6，孩子。
[LAUGHS] I'm like 6 foot now.
（笑）我现在有6英尺了。
Damn!
该死！
Hey, wait. Samuel, will you tell me, what did you think happened to Terrence? I never asked you that.
嘿，等等。Samuel，你愿意告诉我，你以为Terrence发生了什么？我从未问过你。
I actually thought he did not survive Katrina.
我实际上以为他没在卡特里娜飓风中存活下来。
You thought he didn't make it.
你以为他没挺过来。
Yeah. Yeah. In Katrina, like, you hear the death count, but you don't hear who.
是的。是的。在卡特里娜中，就像，你听到死亡人数，但你不知道具体是谁。
Hey, I don't mean to cut you off. Not to cut you off, but you still talk-- like, you got a different accent. But you're still talking and responding the same way from when you were a little kid, son. You were like, uh. And you still do that.
嘿，我不是故意打断你。不是要打断你，但你依然说话——你有不同的口音。但你说话和回应的方式和你小时候一模一样，孩子。你过去常说，呃。你现在依然这样做。
Yeah. They say I have like a dad laugh. That's how they made fun of me here.
是的。他们说我有一种爸爸式的笑声。那就是他们在这里取笑我的方式。
[LAUGHS] Man, I'm not even gonna lie, man. I got a huge burden-- like, this is like a real-- I really feel like you blessed me just now. Like, seriously, it feel good. It feel real good talking to you son, because you were like my best friend, son. Like damn, dude.
（笑）伙计，我甚至不想装模作样，伙计。我背负着巨大的负担——就像这是真实的——我觉得你刚才祝福了我。就像，认真地说，这感觉很好。和你谈话感觉真好，孩子，因为你就像我最好的朋友，孩子。该死，伙计。
Yeah.
是的。
This feel good. This feel good talking to you. I ain't even going to front.
这种感觉真好。和你谈话感觉真好。我甚至不想装。
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, with Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, Lily Sullivan, and Nancy Updike. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is editorial consultant.
好吧，我们的节目今天由Robyn Semien和Zoe Chace、Sean Cole、Stephanie Foo、Chana Joffe-Walt、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar，以及Brian Reed、Alissa Shipp、Lily Sullivan和Nancy Updike制作。我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。Julie Snyder是编辑顾问。
Other editing help this week from David George and Neil Drumming. Additional reporting today by going Laine Kaplan-Levenson. Additional production work from Sachar Mathias. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager.
本周其他编辑帮助来自David George和Neil Drumming。今天额外的报道来自Laine Kaplan-Levenson。额外的制作工作来自Sachar Mathias。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的业务运营经理。
Elna Baker scouts stories for the show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
Elna Baker为节目寻找故事。Kimberly Henderson是我们的办公室协调员。今天的研究帮助来自Christopher Swetala和Michelle Harris。今天音乐方面的帮助来自Damien Graef和Rob Geddis。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, in his early career in broadcasting, he actually fired-- fired-- Eugene Levy from SCTV.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，在他广播生涯的早期，他实际上开除了——开除了——SCTV的Eugene Levy。
It was very difficult to do. That was a very good levee.
这非常困难。那是一个非常好的大堤。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多关于美国生活的故事回来。